it's easy to get gaslit into that
because there was times where it's like
okay
you know i'm hanging out with this
uh for example like you're you're in
that like yoga community and everyone's
super nice
but it's like you try to start drawing
those boundaries
and
it's like oh you know yeah rich one of
those hardcore military guys you know um
you know um big bad mean navy seal
you know doesn't let his poor little
wife do anything you know and so
uh and again like i don't want to have
to be a dictator
in in relationships and that's not my
my my leadership style is i'm more of
the of the line of
um
i'm going to tell you what what needs to
be done or whatever and then you have
the decision
to
to do that or not and a lot of times
i'll give
i was i was telling this from one of my
buddies down in brazil because he was
going through through this stuff with
his girlfriend let me just stop you on
that story for a second i just want to
correct you on something so this is kind
of my wheelhouse for those of you that
are new or the channel watching this
sort of thing so i mean if you're to ask
your woman to do something right the way
that the way that you got to look at it
as a guy is you've got to look at it as
she has three options it's you know she
executes you know so you ask her do
something she executes it uh she's
confused and she needs clarity hey rich
i'm not sure what you mean by this you
want me to do a b and c so then she
comes to you for clarity or three it's
she has a better way to do it and she
comes to you with a different solution
that's really it it's not like you don't
have the option not to do it like if if
you're gonna have responsibility to a
family if you're gonna have a
responsibility to protect a woman
because let's be honest i mean if
there's a bang in the night
there's a big bang downstairs and you're
in bed with your wife your girlfriend
your woman whatever do you just nudge
her and say you go get this one baby you
know because you're a feminist she's
going to expect you to leap out of bed
grab a weapon and go do what you're
supposed to do as a guy because you're
the protector women men and women are
not the same we're not you know the way
that you look at
at that angle you know as far as like
i'm going to give you the option you
have to take that away and you actually
have to say to her you know it needs to
be done and if you're not going to do it
you have to come back with either i'm
confused and look for clarity or i have
a better solution why don't we try this
yeah great point and let me oh so let me
i'll explain on that a little bit
because i think i might have
i said what i said but
in in my thoughts
some of the things that were happening
were
it wasn't i said to begin with it was i
was actually told
right
oh hey
i spoke with my sister
we decided that we're gonna try to go do
this
and now you're put something was already
put in motion conversations were had and
something was put in motion and then you
have to now come in and put the squash
on it and be the [ __ ] who now oh
everyone already agreed on it and
everyone's already planning on this and
now you come in and you're the one who
stopped it
you know what i mean and i did uh so for
exa like
that happened the first time there was
one of these trips and it was a weekend
trip to canada with her sister
then it went to
uh a trip with a couple of her
girlfriends to this island off of
georgia to go camping
then it went to
a trip
a 10-day trip to colorado for like a
yoga trainer experience
you know then it went to oh we're gonna
go to southam central america and go do
this thing for two weeks with a couple
of these friends and i said at that
point i was like no
that's not a wife though rich like
that's not what a wife does yeah yeah
like women with boyfriends or with
husbands don't go away for weekends to
vegas or whatever with their girlfriends
they just don't yeah and if they want to
do it then you just say okay fine i
don't date women like that yeah right i
mean like you have to like kind of quash
it early on like you can't let it get to
a marriage you know sort of scenario so
if it's like if you're dating her and
she's like hey i'm gonna go to my vegas
girlfriend's weekend you know quarterly
sort of thing and it's like okay well i
don't date women like that right
yeah
it's you know just as simple as that and
then it's a disqualification so you
don't have to deal with that later on
down the road so you're ending up in a
scenario where it's like you're married
for a while and it like this is the
fourth trip in like three months or
something like that where she's going
away you know with her girlfriends
because you know like i mean for those
of you guys watching you know that i
have a mclaren if you've watched for a
while i wouldn't park my car in a shitty
neighborhood leave it unlocked and throw
the keys in the scene just walk away
from it and hope for the best it's the
same thing with your woman
right you don't let her get into a
scenario where she could potentially
uh betray you
if you know what i'm saying like men
cheat women betray right like there's a
difference
so that's that's essentially you say
that men cheat women betray so let me go
one more step with this and that's what
happened
so they wanted to do the trip to central
america and i said no you guys don't
know about leaving the country like
mexico is super dangerous
the you guys aren't going as especially
without having one of us go with you
and they're like oh well you don't think
we can do it like we're
wrong independent women blah blah i'm
like i get it but no you're not going
there you're not going for freaking two
weeks down there yeah and i that's like
enough is enough and i drew the line on
it and i squashed it yeah so after that
they they all got really upset with me
because i was like
now the big bad neighbors
they're controlling husband
right so then what happens is
she opens up credit cards behind my back
and opens up a bank account behind my
back
and starts planning
a month-long trip to thailand
without me knowing
and about two weeks prior to her leaving
she she tells me
that
uh
that she's going to thailand for two
weeks to go or for a month
two weeks prior to her leaving she tells
me and
i'm like well with with what what
you know what i mean and oh well don't
worry about it because i i have my own
bank account and credit card etc etc and
i'm like no you don't have your own
because we're married so anything that
you own a credit card if you don't pay
it i have to pay it right if your bank
account gets stolen or your credit card
gets stolen in thailand guess who
they're going to come after like because
we're married that's how that works you
know and
was she was she generating income in the
household or
was it mostly yeah
just a little bit you know she's a yoga
teacher so she taught like two or three
times a week and she would go do
some day jobs here and there so it was
like the eddie murphy stand up it's like
here rich here's 80 dollars because i
want to do my share
yeah yeah kind of like that exactly so
at that point
you know the betrayal had come in to
where strong and independent sorry like
but this is the thing like little stuff
like this
hey there's this app or this website
where you can go and you can go on and
order meals and they send you a meal
with all the ingredients and the
instructions and it's it shows up your
door it's on like a block of you know
ice block ice it's like a chef's plate
you kind of make it falling you just
make it she's like hey i think it would
be really cool for us to cook together
okay yeah you know maybe that would be a
good thing so
we start or we do like three dinners
together in the kitchen
and then it's like hey
uh i gotta go teach tonight but i
ordered that home chef so
you can you can fix yourself dinner
there's stuff here etc etc and she kept
dropping this thing this little quote
where she would say like i'm not always
going to be here to feed you you got to
learn how to cook you know what i mean
like you can't always count on me to
make your meal there might be some times
where
i'm not going to be here that you need
to make the meal did you forget that you
would eat like mres out of a pouch like
you know you could feed it yeah i just
eat a freaking peanut butter jelly
sandwich or a salad or whatever
but do you see what i'm saying so yeah
yeah she knew in her head that she was
going to be going and she was setting up
for this trip for a month so she was
bringing this food in
let's do a couple meals together hey why
don't you do this on your own
i'm not always going to be here to cook
for you oh by the way i'm leaving for a
month
you know what i mean so it was at this
point it was kind of like it clicked and
that like all of a sudden when she told
me that i kind of rewound all these
conversations and things that had
transpired and it was like
if i had said no to mexico
for a two-week trip what in the world
makes you think that going to thailand
for a month would be better
and that's where i just said hey
you're going to do whatever you're going
to do
but just understand i'm going to make
decisions based on what what you decide
did you guys have any kids
no okay so i mean like you got out of
that pretty much uh yeah without free
with you so at that point
at that point that's what i'm kind of
saying it was like
i'm not going to tell you no
because i know you're already doing
things to deceive me and i basically
gave the rope yeah and he said
you're going to go if you're going to go
because if you don't go you're going to
do something like this again in some
other way and
so let's see what you do i'm saying i
think this is a bad idea and i would not
like you to go i want you to stay here i
want you to cancel this cancel those
credit cards yeah but i'm gonna let you
do what you want to do have you read my
book where did you go and that's where i
was like all right fine that's cool i'm
getting divorced because i'm not going
to live in a relationship like this
because this isn't a this isn't a
functional healthy relationship
um no it's not it's not conducive at all
have you read my book
not yet
so i talk about um beta tization by a
thousand concessions i mean if you have
long drives grab the audio version it's
it's like a four and a half hour listen
so i mean you can rip through it pretty
quick but um i talk about beta tization
through a thousand concessions in it and
basically
you know like it starts with something
simple like hey rich let's go vegan
together or let's go and do this retreat
together or put your white socks in a
white hamper and your dark socks in a
dark hamper
then it turns into something else and
then it turns into you know basically
what you
ended up with and it's not like any one
thing breaks the camel's back it's just
a sequence of a whole bunch of
concessions that you make you know then
you get married then you make a whole
bunch more concessions and it's like you
know you get to the point where it's
like
i've i've got all the responsibility
here as the man in the house as
what should be the head of the household
is the protector i mean [ __ ] your navy
seals for crying out loud
and i have no authority
at all and it's why you really have to
early on at the start of the
relationship set the frame
to
who's who's going to be in whose frame
and she needs to be in your frame you
know just just for clarity for those
that are wondering
because that because then you never get
to the point where she's taking all
these trips and i don't need no man and
i'm not going to come to you to this you
know and support you you know with this
gala mar-a-lago and all that stuff